Це українські Карпати. А це - туристи з арабських країн.
Відео, як туристи з "теплих" країв радіють снігу в Карпатах, розходяться в соцмережах як гарячі пиріжки.
З арабського боку немає снігу! Не падає! Тому це так!  У нас же скрізь пісок. Так, є гори, але таких ось місць немає.
Мухаммед навчався у Львівському університеті на інженера, але краще говорить російською, ніж українською.
Каже, ніколи не думав, що зароблятиме саме на знанні слов’янських мов,
працюючи туристичним гідом для арабських туристів в Україні.
"Арабський бум", як це називають місцеві, почався у Карпатах улітку.
Відтоді у Мухаммеда немає часу на відпочинок.
Раніше не приїжджали. Цього року влітку вперше приїхали. Я сам був в шоці, що приїхали.
Причин такого "арабського буму" в Карпатах кілька.
По-перше, через пандемію традиційні місця відпочинку для туристів з цих країн виявилися закритими.
По-друге, президент України Володимир Зеленський торік запровадив "безвіз" для громадян країн Аравійського півострова.
Турист із Саудівської Аравії Бадур цілком задоволений такою ситуацією.
Був у Карпатах влітку, вирішив приїхати ще взимку.
Підйомник йому дуже сподобався.
Вчора там були, і він був дуже задоволений.
Озеро дуже сподобалося біля водоспаду.
І, як він каже, йому дуже сподобалася саме шаурма.
Арабські туристи за мусульманською традицією вживають лише халяльні продукти.
Тож, можна сказати, що, починаючи з літа, шаурма халяль стала
такою ж невід’ємною частиною української гостинності в Карпатах, як і гуцульська кухня.
Власниця кіоску шаурми і продуктової крамниці в селищі Поляниця, де розташований курорт "Буковель",
Юлія Шевченко розповідає, що завдяки туристам з арабських країн її бізнес ішов дуже успішно.
Ми навіть після того, як сезон літній закінчився, нічого не міняли.
Ми на халяльному м’ясі, хай воно і дорожче, на ньому продовжуємо працювати. Для всіх!
Юлія не змінювала й асортимент в своїй крамниці.
Улітку налагодила контакти з надійними постачальниками халяльних продуктів.
У неї є запас і айрану, і халяльного молока, і рису басматі, і курятини із сертифікатом халяль.
Улітку тримали в морозилках по 100-150 курей. І завозили щодня. Тому що вони не мали де їх купити.
За словами Юлії, також багато хто з місцевих фермерів перепрофілювалися з вирощування свиней та корів на баранів та овець.
Вони їх тут практично усіх купили та з’їли, скажімо так.
Вони тут скрізь ходили, шукали баранину.
Якщо раніше ці барани нікому не потрібні були, коштували три копійки, то влітку ціни доходили до 3-4-х тисяч. Космос якийсь!
Місцеві підприємці швидко встановили рожни і мангали для баранячого м'яса.
У ресторанах кажуть, попит на халяль був величезний.
М’яке, ніжне, не відчувається смаку баранини.
Деякі локації навіть спеціально наймали додатковий персонал для арабських туристів.
А готелі відчували великий дефіцит арабськомовних гідів.
Лише за даними пресслужби курорту "Буковель", з травня по листопад тут побували 30000 туристів із Саудівської Аравії та Катару.
Наразі туристів з арабських країн у "Буковелі" ще мало.
Їх очікують ближче до весни. І до цього активно готуються й місцеві підприємці.
У селищі Поляниця вивіски арабською ледь не на кожному магазині.
Готелі замовляють нові вказівники арабською, ресторани - оновлене меню арабською з новим халяльним меню.
Сулугуні, бринза й айран. Усе халяльне. Бринза овеча.
Місцеві підприємці розраховують, що "арабський бум" не стане тимчасовим явищем для Карпат.
Вони повернуться до нас знову. Більше того, ми маємо фактичне підтвердження від авіакомпаній та турагенцій,
які займаються обслуговуванням цієї категорії туристів, що навесні навіть ще більша кількість арабських гостей приїде до України.
Разом з тим місцеві підприємці акцентують, що Карпати ніколи не перетворяться на переважно арабський  курорт.
Представник готельно-ресторанної мережі "Картель" Герман Ільницький каже,
що попри пандемію тут багато туристів із сусідніх Молдови, Білорусі, країн ЄС.
Карпати так само можуть привабити і туристів з Китаю, для яких Україна вже запроваджувала тимчасовий "безвіз".
Ми не фокусуємося тільки на арабських туристах.
Є ще китайські туристи. Це теж інша ментальність, і нас очікують ці зміни попереду.
Ціни на карпатських курортах постійно повзуть вгору.
Але іноземців, схоже, це не лякає.
Те, що в Карпати їдуть лише шейхи - це байка, каже арабськомовний гід Мухаммед.
Здебільшого він бачить тут середній клас: вчителів, лікарів тощо.
Усі приїжджають: і багаті, і середній клас.
Є люди, в яких маленька зарплата. Вони тут відпочивають, аби підтримати настрій.
Деякі послуги в Карпатах вже навіть дорожчі, ніж у країнах ЄС.
Українські туристи побоюються, що зимовий відпочинок в українських горах стане для них недоступним.
Дорого. Ось, взяли кілька вареників за 500 грв. Ну, і підйомники - 1050 грв на день.
У місцевій ОТГ натомість дуже задоволені такими темпами розвитку туризму.
У Поляницьку громаду входять чотири гірські селища, які раніше займалися переважно сільським та лісовим господарством.
Нині усі так чи інакше задіяні в туризмі і непогано заробляють.
Настільки, що на заробітки за кордон майже ніхто не виїжджає.
Ні, наша молодь не їде за кордон. Вона знаходить тут робочі місця.
Оскільки робочих місць у нас багато. Різні заробітні плати отримують. Необхідності у цьому зараз немає.
Близько половини підприємців, які працюють на території ОТГ, з інших регіонів,
відповідно податки сплачують іншим громадам. Але й надходжень від місцевих теж вистачає.
Загальний бюджет ми мали 114 мільйонів.
Оплата податку на землю, оплата податку на нерухомість - це великі надходження.
Туристичного збору багато немає, десь відсотків 12-15% від надходжень,
оскільки туристичний збір не такий вже й великий.
Прибуток нашої громади - найбільший в області, якщо брати такі територіальні громади, як ми.
Комунальних земель на продаж уже немає - все розкупили.
Проте в селищі очікують бум з продажу приватних ділянок.
Ціни на землю постійно зростають. Як і ціни на нерухомість.
А туристи з арабських країн вже стали потенційними покупцями.
Вони розглядають такий варіант як дачу.
Дуже багато з цих туристів - літні люди.
Це не як раніше - якийсь секс-туризм, що молоді хлопці приїжджали.
Переважно це сімейні люди, серед яких є літні, яким просто легше дихаєтеся в Карпатах.
Турист із Саудівської Аравії Бадур хоче ще раз повернутися в Карпати. Вже не один.
Велика родина?
Ні.  Одна мадам!
Зі своєю мадам Бадур планує приїхати через два місяці.
Очікується, що початок гарячого сезону "арабського буму" припаде на травень.